everybody has sex when you come to a sex
shop
don't deep throat a dildo nope it's
ain't no touchy-touchy shaved off lip
tonight thank each other not around us
because we didn't give you consent and
we don't want to see it people should
act like an adult in an adult store save
for shenanigans for your home we love
you we love the fact that you want to
buy all this stuff and that you're so
excited to try it but try it at home can
I tell you a little story a lot of them
they could strain out one of those
things if I hear from the other one is
for my mistress which one should I
decide that's your burro that's it you
buy them under you right the best we
don't push sales we launched what about
that guy who used his wife's card to buy
his girlfriend something Wow my favorite
story so far is of a person who came in
and purchased clue which I was so
excited for because it's one of those
things that people gloss over um however
they also excuse the bathroom and
knocked on the door and heard noises but
I was not prepared to hear it's just
really awkward after that so just don't
masturbate in public don't please
people used to go to the bathroom and
then we would be missing you know
displays of butt plugs like hiding toys
and their bodies and then leaving and
walking out of the store like a-plus for
effort I guess but f- on the fact that
it's a display boy I don't want to shame
anybody but everybody in New York
touches our toys you're gonna want a
clean one before you do that anyway and
lubricant I'm sure they didn't do it
with loose
everybody is different everybody's
bodies different so it's good to go to
stores because you can get educated you
can see and feel things it's different
from looking online because it could
look like it's this small and then in
person it's like so big protip testing
the vibrators on your nose will be
similar to the nerve sensitivity of like
your other bits don't feel ashamed
nobody's gonna judge you and even if
there's customers in there they're in
there too so they're not gonna judge you
because they're in there to just feel
like comedies like we're here for you
what do you want to buy we have the best
toy see anybody can dream from little
one big ones you go through that door
are you going to paradise you get home
folks come in and try to purchase
services other than the education of sex
toys do not ask if we have the toys if
we use the toys it'd be kind of silly if
we worked in a sex shop and didn't have
any toys for many many reasons you know
we all got a benefit somehow you know
ask questions respectfully don't ask me
what my favorite thing is cuz I
guarantee we're not on the same
wavelength we may know that you are
looking for a butt plug but I don't know
your last name
so let's keep it there we're here to
sell you things help us out help you
find out what you want because we just
met you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]